wenn euch die Pasta Rezepte ausgeht
probiert mal diese unglaubliche Pasta
aller Norma unser main character ist die
Aubergine dazu noch passierte Tomaten
Basilikum eine Mutanten Knoblauchzehe
und Pecorino erster Aufgabe Aubergine in
Würfel schneiden jetzt nehmen wir uns
ein bisschen Salz und streuen es über
unsere Auberginen von allen Seiten ganz
wichtig wir wollen dass die Feuchtigkeit
und auch die Bitterstoffe rausgezogen
werden und jetzt zum Trocknen auf ein
Blech schaut euch das einfach mal an was
jetzt schon rausgekommen ist ohne dass
wir das Ganze einmal abgetopft haben und
Auberginen in die Pfanne in ordentlich
Olivenöl so dass hier echt drin
schwimmen können und hier braten wir sie
richtig schön durch so sieht unsere
Aubergine nach einigen Minuten aus das
heißt es ist Zeit für uns die passt da
hineinzugeben und wir holen die
Auberginen raus und geben sie auf in das
Öl das zurückgeblieben ist
zurückgeblieben geben jetzt Knoblauch
passierte Tomaten und Basilikum einfach
im Ganzen können wir später rausfischen
jetzt können wir auch schon die Metzger
der Toni rüber geben ruhig ein zwei
Minuten bevor sie fertig gekocht sind
und jetzt gehen wir unsere Aubergine
wieder dazu und fertig ist unsere
wunderschöne Pasta aller nor